okay so a to the Cossacks now just as I
am for a log I think you are going to be
mildly frustrated with yourself if you
found this difficult because all this is
is chain rule right and it's actually
not that hard for chaining now by this
time you guys been doing chain rule for
a long time so you've probably got into
the habit of skipping let u equal blob
of line you do the substitution because
you sort of do it in your hair right
that's fine when you're meeting
something familiar it really would be a
waste of time to let u equal the inside
function and so on but when you're
meeting something that you're not that
familiar with it's worth it and then you
see how easy is actually did okay so
what do you suggest I use is my
substitution what's my inside function
it's just it's just chris i'm so i'm
going to say let u equal closet ok so
now i just think chain rule ok what does
chain rule require you to do first will
differentiate the inside function so you
so do you on the ass ok cars turns into
minus sign
you've done the inside now you got to
the outside okay so in order to do the
outside I need to rephrase it in terms
of my substitution okay so this is no
longer a to the Cossacks is just Y is a
to the you okay so that looks weird but
if it was any other better like it was
ex and the X because they had a
differentiated yet so if i differentiate
anything u with respect to you okay this
is just any old concert right
unfortunately it's not easy so it makes
a little bit trickier but not that much
it's just either you log a right
remember that which is why the special
case where it's e to the U this part
here becomes log eating which is why it
just vanishes because one alright so now
change dy DX which is what I was after
in the first place is do you want u
times to you on yeah okay and for this
next line I just want to put these in
but I might as well at the same time get
rid of all the use right because there's
only one left over that mean they're so
i'll just type it back for what it is so
this is minus sine X and to the cos x
log it's not working that's it that's us
that's as simple as it gets so I know we
kind of forgot a scoff at doing the full
form of chain rule I thought what a
waste of time that's not general news
right but it really helps if it's a
function which are you haven't met
before but it's not really that hard
like it's it's so few lines at work here
and you could even escape this line here
just once right there okay that